[Applaudissements]
la Suisse paisible ces belles montagnes
sont délicieux fromage et évidemment
Heidi
[Musique]
je t'aime poupée
mais vous n'avez encore rien vu la
citoyen aujourd'hui tout
ça c'est dans les mains du nouvel an
est accusé de production de produits
laitiers illégaux
aujourd'hui la jeune fille des Alpes et
de retour
pour se venger
préparez-vous à l'action des jolies
filles suisses
des katanas de l'armée suisse et bien
sûr
de la conduit bien onctueuse oh j'adore
l'odeur du fromage au petit matin oui
peut-être plus jamais un fromage de la
même façon
Aladdin
le seul pauvre fromage est le fromage
frit
[Musique]
est une sacrée dure à cuire elle est
malade
il y a quelque chose qui gigote dans mon
futur